what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro back at it again to discuss
the latest developments in the bordeaux
story
we got absolutely crazy twists and turns
in this
chapter so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing naruto and
boruto videos on this channel i want to
keep them coming then the best thing you
can do is smash that like button and
share this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto slash
portal videos so if you haven't yet
make this the day you subscribe and as
you wait for the next porto chapter or
video to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
slash boruto playlist where i got videos
about the hokage
all otsutsuki clan members all uzumaki
clan members
and most recently all 27 kage and their
powers
explained links to the playlist and the
new kage video can be found in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called
that's reality a title that does not
bode too well for our characters at all
the cover of this one features a cool
looking kawaki and you gotta love this
dude's hairstyle
as mentioned last chapter the creator of
naruto kishimoto is now back in the
driver's seat of the story which for
many naruto fans including me
raises the borto hype even more add
naruto's new form and we have boruto
being better than it's ever been
and this chapter was just as
action-packed as the last one
but more tragic this one begins with
kawaki on the ground after being
transported by ishiki
he was able to bring him here because
kawaki's artificial arm with naruto's
chakra helped ishiki locate his desired
vessel's location
baryon mode naruto and sasuke are
shocked by this
and they're all pretty beaten up
including ishiki whose time is running
out quick
we jump to a motto and the others and a
model still pretty cool calm and
collected
on the outside says that if ishiki did
take kauki they're out of options
they're completely done for not a very
reassuring conclusion from our scientist
here however the hope is that naruto's
baryon mode
was enough to make sure that ishiki dies
before he succeeds and implanting his
karma into kawaki again
ishiki proceeds to count his chickens
before they hatch and assumes it's over
he won already in his mind but still he
acknowledges that it was a close call
and he only has five minutes left kawaki
recalls what amato said that even a
monster
can't escape death and instead of giving
up he focuses on trying to last for five
minutes so they can win
kind of not too smart of ishiki to
reveal how much time he has left and
kawaki is cocky too
saying stuff like he's glad ishiki
brought him here so he can witness the
end of his worthless life
talking to an otsutuki like that who
believe that they are infinitely
superior to humans
is great to see remember ishiki's goal
here is just to implant the karma and
then he can totally die no problem yeah
he won't resurrect right away but he
will eventually when the karma matures
naruto tells kawaki to run but he
doesn't have as much energy left as
ishiki ishiki delivers a blow to naruto
and he loses his baryon mode
this to me is kind of a good sign he
reverted back to normal and he's still
alive
again we don't know what the full
repercussions of using baryon mode
are going to be we just know that kurama
thought it would mean death
just as it all seems to be over and
ishiki is holding kaaki by the throat
sasuke uses his powers to switch places
with kawaki again i love how everyone is
playing their part here
sasuke gave kabuki some important
distance and also some smoke grenades
that are immune to the byakugan's powers
although sasuke is physically powerless
against ishiki and gets punched to the
ground
his strategy was great and very useful
here i love how he had left those smoke
grenades there on his feet before
switching places
the smoke only lasts a few minutes but
that's all they need
so mission seemingly accomplished but
and you know there's going to be a but
as we know villains don't give up that
easily and ishiki decides to use
naruto as a hostage he starts beating up
naruto so bad
kawaki's arm falls off showing that
naruto is seriously not in a good
position right now ishiki then gives
kawaki
20 seconds to show up or he'll kill
naruto when he only has a few minutes
left to live i wonder why he didn't give
like 10 seconds or something but
whatever the reason he gives 20 valuable
seconds in a situation where every
second counts we get a powerful
flashback of kawaki hiding from jigen
only to be found out
then jigen prepares to punish him with
his pull from the flashback it's implied
that this happened many times
so we can well assume that kawaki is
traumatized naruto's childhood was hard
and lonely there's no doubt about that
but kawaki was also punished mercilessly
and was trapped rather than allowed to
roam free that's why it's all the more
touching and powerful when after
remembering the kindness naruto showed
him
kawaki decides to give himself over with
less than a second left by the way bonus
points for kawaki
who made the most of the situation by
fully using those 20 important seconds
he uses fire release showing the fruits
of his ninjutsu training with naruto who
actually said that kawaki has a knack
for it but it seems to be no use
ishiki has caught him he insults him for
trying to be a ninja and trying to be
anything for that matter
he tells him he has no future besides
being sacrificed as ishiki's vessel and
we get some very powerful moments here
from kawaki again
making me respect him a lot i think
kawaki probably shines the most in this
entire chapter out of everyone he says
he was
empty but naruto gave him a reason to
live and in this time we live in where a
lot of people are especially in need of
a sense of meaning in their lives
a line like that hits home there's a
difference between simply existing and
truly living and naruto helped kalaki
realize that
then ishiki mentions the title of this
chapter when he says
who cares that naruto gave you a reason
to live when the reality of the
situation is
that kawaki was captured because of the
arm naruto gave him
and because of the affection he gave him
kawaki gave himself up
kawaki simply says that ishiki doesn't
understand a thing
and that a world without naruto has no
worth to him
kawaki would rather die than lose naruto
i'm sure if you asked kawaki if his life
before naruto was better than death he
would have said
no so even if he dies now he's still
super grateful that naruto took him out
of that deathlike meaningless existence
if only for a short period of time
and kawaki's actions here are really
brave and really honorable it really
makes me wonder how someone with so much
honor and such a strong moral compass
could end up being the kawaki we see
after the time skip in naruto we are
often introduced to a bad guy who
becomes a good guy
but here it seems that kawaki who's
willing to sacrifice his
own life for naruto right now will
actually end up being
boruto's main adversary it's crazy to
think about but right now i can't help
but be moved by kawaki's behavior and
actions
ishiki really doesn't care about any of
this emotional and honorable stuff
though he's like whatever the point is
you're just a vessel for me
he laughs like the joker as things seem
like they're all over the karma is back
on kawaki
however kishimoto is not done with the
twists
as it turns out kawaki's training in
ninjutsu was invaluable because it
taught him how to create shadow clones
and just when ishiki is about to die
happily with his mission accomplished
kabuki erases the karma marks on his
body ishiki is freaking out like never
before now and that's when the real
kawaki appears
and reveals that the other one is a
shadow clone love the use of strategy in
this chapter from sasuke's smoke
grenades and kawaki's shadow clone and i
also love the fact that everybody played
a crucial role
in buying time so they could finally win
and you gotta love how kawaki rubs it in
saying to ishiki who views them as lower
life forms or insect that he's gonna die
because he was totally outsmarted and
beaten by a mere vessel
and in fact this is his reality what an
amazing moment this
is although it leaves me wondering how
is kawaki going to get his karma
which we know he will get eventually but
on to the thing
we've been dying to know sasuke is beat
up for sure but he's curious about
naruto and the baryon mode
both kawaki and he along with us want
naruto to let them know
about the serious risk to that power and
what the consequences will be
but before naruto can explain boruto
possessed by momoshiki
stabs sasuke's renagon this means that
sasuke might have just lost his ability
to shift spaces
create portals to other dimensions and
more possibly forever
and it makes sense that momoshiki would
go for it since the rinnegan's powers
did annoy ishiki
a lot this is a huge loss and tragedy
for
sasuke especially after he was already
useless against ishiki's power
compared to naruto's baryon mode so we
are close to the end of this chapter and
now we have the situation with naruto
and the consequences of the baryon mode
being unclear
sasuke's rinagon potentially being
unusable forever and boruto taken over
by momoshiki
who would have thought that things would
look this bad
after they finally managed to defeat
ishiki momoshiki says he never thought
they would actually defeat ishiki but
he's glad because now they are the only
nuisances left
we don't know what he'll do whether
he'll go for the kill or if he'll leave
them in another dimension or what but
things do not look good
what a cliffhanger this is kishimoto is
really trying to make every chapter
count right now and i can't wait to see
where we go from here especially since
the stakes are so high and we got so
many
unanswered questions and that is it for
this video as always let me know your
thoughts on the chapter and what you
expect to see happening next in the
comments
if you do enjoy seeing naruto and boruto
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you can
do is smash that like button and share
this video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select all or you
will miss
future naruto such porto videos so if
you haven't yet
make this the day you subscribe and as
you wait for the next boruto chapter or
video to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
playlist where i got videos about the
hokage
dotsutsuki the ozumaki and most recently
all 27 kage and their powers explained
which is actually
our longest naruto video on the channel
so make sure to check that out a lot of
interesting information there
links to the playlist and to the new
kanye video can be found
in the description and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you